als ich mich zwingen wir es nicht nach
reden ich bin der trauer helfen wollen
sie ihm ein paar fragen stellen also was
ist dass wir für eine versammlung ist
csi triple
ich bin großer fan dieses wird es auf
jeden fall ist unfassbar unterhaltsam
ist unfassbar witzig mitunter auch es
gibt alles was man eigentlich in so
einem krimi erwarten würde von
verfolgungsjagten geheim türen in alten
häusern prep messer die eigentlich gar
keinen richtigen messer sind also haufen
krempel der irgendwie da rein gebracht
wird er aber auf eine ganz tolle art
zusammengesetzt wird so dass man
wirklich sehr viel spaß hat seines todes
hat die familie also gemeinsam den 85
geburtstag ihres vaters gefeiert sie
glauben einer aus der familie hatte
[ __ ] gebracht das wollen sie andeuten
unfassbar spannend wie das ganze gedreht
wird wenn man nämlich schon dreimal
denkt man hat jetzt raus wer wie der
mord gelaufen ist kommt noch mal eine
überraschung um die ecke was ja super
viel spaß macht wenn man sich sowas
gerne anguckt die familie ist zutiefst
verzweifelt und in der verzweiflung
türken die menschen gerne die messer
regen hatte ich wenn's denn die
beerdigung lässt ja aus über zu
testament der regisseur rian johnson hat
sich seinen traum credo brettspiel
besetzung zusammen gecastet also wir
haben jamie lee curtis als sehr bissige
ambitionierte tochter wir haben don
johnson als ihren ehemann christopher
plummer spielt einen sehr reichen
schriftsteller der das so viel kann
verraten werden die leiche sein wird
über den größten teil des films daniel
craig ist mit dabei der schuldigen
tollen detektiv spielt der irgendwie die
polizei mit unterstützen muss wieso sind
sie hier
ich vermute fremd ein bürger und die
ganz großartige ana de armas sehr willig
alle belogen eigentlich aus kuba hat so
ganz kleine film steps bis jetzt gemacht
und ist hier aber eigentlich die
hauptfigur obwohl sie in diesem haushalt
in diesem sehr reichen haushalt
eigentlich nur eine nebenfigur ist sie
kümmert sich medizinisch um den die
gesundheit des reichen schriftstellers
und hat aber ein ganz enges verhältnis
mit ihm über die zeit aufnahmen seines
todes hat die familie also gemeinsam den
85 geburtstag ihres vaters gefragt
die party vor vaters tod
womit wir eigentlich schon bei dem sind
was ryan johnson mit dem film macht also
der es so einen regisseur der immer die
chance sich nimmt und sie dann verbiegt
und und anguckt und auseinandernimmt und
schaut wasser wir durch so ein sohn
chris man damit machen kann in welche
ecke näher sie drängen kann der hat
angefangen mit einem film der heißt
übrig war ganz klassische story also typ
sucht den mörder seiner freundin eine
holly eine highschool gelegt hat in
amerika und er hat auch den letzten die
episode 8 von star wars gemacht also dem
finden der so ein bisschen für furore
sorgte weil er auch so die grenzen
testete mit was kann man eigentlich mit
diesem star wars nummer noch machen und
wie kann man diese wenn man sich die
wirklich mal anguckt als figuren wie wie
kann man die so ein bisschen drehen und
wo können sie eigentlich was lernen und
was kann man da noch rausholen
[Musik]
johnson hat in den in den notizen
sozusagen zum film gesagt dass er sich
sehr viel agatha christie angeguckt hat
von dem man immer denkt eigentlich ist
überhaupt nicht politisch das ist so
unterhaltsames krimi ding wo halten
mörder gefunden werden muss aber
eigentlich wenn man sich wirklich die
strukturen anguckt guckt sie halt auf
die bediensteten die butler das was
alles unter der ganzen oberschicht in
großbritannien sozusagen los warum geht
in die bereiche die man sonst eigentlich
gar nicht so den blick geworfen hat und
johnson adaptiert das sozusagen diese
diese klassische britische sache und
sagt was kann man damit eigentlich im
heutigen amerika machen was ist denn
wenn wir uns einen landsitz benehmen der
halt in amerika liegt an der ostküste
und eine sehr reiche familie und uns
angucken wie da die strukturen sind und
das ist sehr interessant was er daraus
macht denn das ist ein sehr
interessantes spektrum auf sämtliche
politischen diskurse die wir momentan
amerika haben die hier im kleinen
verhandelt werden der kern des der blog
ist privatdetektiv vom bistum ruhig habe
ein tweet über einen artikel im new
yorker über sie gelesen
sie sind beruhigt er ist jemand der
eigentlich immer seine filme selbst
schreibt und dann auch umsetzt weil er
weil er weiß wie er das machen will
er hat einen kameramann mit dem in jedem
seiner filme zusammen gearbeitet hat das
heißt auch die kamera spielt sehr mit
seinen visionen zusammen was hier
eigentlich die geschichte ist die
erzählt werden soll das heißt der
kameramann unterstützt teilweise schon
so halb psychologisch das was er machen
will das heißt wir haben ganz tollen
bildaufbau wir haben unfassbar viele
details in diesem haus also auch das
setdesign ist wirklich einmalig toll die
schauspieler sowieso also es ist
wirklich ganz toll unterhaltung
ich vermute fremde einwirkung
und ich aber noch keinen als
verdächtiger ausgeschlossen es kaum noch
alle rein gehen die über die feiertage
festgestellt haben mein gott familien
unfassbar anstrengend was soll das
eigentlich alles die kann er sich
hervorragend abarbeiten einer schlacht
leck mich rechtlich so was schon und ist
um alle rein gehen die sich irgendwie
für amerika interessieren und wissen
wollen was mit dieser amerikanischen
gesellschaft eigentlich so schief
gelaufen ist dass wir die situation
haben die welt gerade haben
[Musik]